so i want to take a time
in this edition of what to watch we
often share stories that bring light and
we're going to do a little bit of that
today we want to bring you more details
about the incredible act of kindness
that lily luciano and uvalde texas
mentioned earlier
often during tragic events while people
rightfully mourn and others wonder what
they can do there are some who are
actually spurred to action and in the
words of robert f kennedy they try to
make gentle the life of this world so
let me introduce you to trey gannon he
is the man who created 19 custom caskets
for victims of last week's school
shooting he met with their families so
that he could learn about their
interests and incorporate them into
special designs like superheroes
tick-tock or dinosaurs and one of the 19
caskets will be for a teacher who died
defending her students gannon is
covering the cost of her casket and all
the others which normally guy sells for
thousands of dollars a piece the name of
his company is soul shine that's why i
played that song the almond brother song
soul shine let your soul shine better
than sunshine yeah i'm sure better than
rain uh better than moonshine is what
actually lyrics say i want to play for
you what ganim said about the work and
what it means to him
being able to go to the homes is
something that's very emotional for me
it's not a box anymore it is a
beautiful creation that represents the
loved ones
he worked day and night with his 25 year
old son 20 hours to get these caskets
ready there were other people dozens of
other people who participated in helping
him marisol gonzalez of soul art designs
and justin watts of the graphic house
helped him uh he worked with his close
friend bubba hoffman who hired a texas
truckee company to make the 26 hour
journey from texas to georgia and then
back to texas